back to Washington journal for about the
next hour we're joined by the author of
this book which is called secrecy and
power the life of J Edgar Hoover by
Richard GUID powers mr. powers thank you
very much for being with us this morning
god be with you and I want to ask you I
want to open up we're going to talk
about J Edgar Hoover for about the next
hour and his impact on American law
enforcement and on civil rights in the
United States let me ask you a question
I just asked of the website
administrator recent in 20 minutes ago
what are the best and worst things that
J Edgar Hoover did in his career at
several moments in the nation's history
when the country needed reassurance and
needed a sense of security and that was
primarily during the Depression of the
1930s and during World War two Hoover
gave them that sense of security and so
he supplied the country with something
that it needed very badly
was the best thing that he did the worst
thing that he did was to stay on too
long to the point where his personal
idiosyncrasies and they were very
pleasant ones they were and in Timothy
to nearly any kind of descent in the
country turned the FBI into a repressive
organization and perhaps even worse a
secret repressive organization that was
doing things that were illegal and it
was keeping them from the attention of
the Attorney General and the president
now you've got some terrific pictures in
the book and maybe we can show those in
a minute here the young J Edgar Hoover
tell us a little bit about what he was
like when he was growing up he was born
right here in Washington DC was he not
he was he was born behind the Capitol
building
Ravin near the Library of Congress he
came from a civil servant family he was
born in 1895 and he participated in the
life of middle-class white civil servant
Washington he was an upwards driver and
he went to the best public high school
in Washington he excelled at school he
also excelled as a leader he was the
head of the Cadet Corps which was a an
important after schools activity in
those days he was also
a prize debater but perhaps one of the
most important things about his boyhood
was that Washington DC was a relatively
late place to be segregated it began to
be segregated while Jay Grover was a
young boy and so during his most
formative years one of the primary
impressions that he received was that a
respectable society should be segregated
and furthermore an elite organization
meant a lily-white organization if we'd
met him when he was in his teens and
early 20s what kind of a guy would we
have expected to see well first of all
and a lot of people will be surprised at
this I think you would have found him
likeable and impressive in a an eager
beaver kind of way he was someone of
tremendous intensity he was a person
that would give you a hundred and fifty
percent of any effort that was required
and as a result particularly when he was
given his first jobs in the Justice
Department his superiors were seasoned
politicians and perhaps even politicians
someone over the hill and they were kind
of bowled over by his energy and so
initially it was his competence and his
just fierce energy that set him apart
from his competitors I want to invite
our viewers and our listeners into this
conversation we have three lines
Democrats can call in 202 five eight
five three eight eight one Republicans
202 585 three eight eight zero and
independents and everybody else 202
585 382 we're talking with Richard kid
powers he's the author of secrecy and
power the life of J Edgar Hoover what
was his first real job coming out of
school and after he got his law degree
at George Washington University here in
DC practically simultaneously with
getting that degree he went into the
Justice Department it's a little unclear
what his title was he was a clerk and he
was in an organization called the alien
enemy Bureau and an alien enemy is
particularly --gel category that the
president proclaims after declaration of
war
and what it means is that people who are
citizens of a country that the United
States is fighting are liable to
internment and Hoover's job initially
was to go through applications for
exemption from internment and so he was
thrown right into the problem of dealing
with immigrants who were suspicious in
one way or another and probably a
suspicion of immigrants was something
that stayed with him the rest of his
life all the way through until his
anti-communist days after World War two
exactly and how did he get we wanted
we've got calls coming in for you
already but you want to do - one quick
thing here how did he get to what was
then called the Bureau of Investigation
in April and May of 1919 there were a
series of bomb attacks terrorist bomb
explosions throughout the country and in
the summer of 1919 the Attorney General
of the United States a mitchell Palmer
decided to form an anti radical division
of the Justice Department and he put J
Edgar Hoover in charge of it now Jake
Hoover was only 24 years old at the time
initially he was a special assistant to
the Attorney General but in essence he
was supervising the Bureau of
Investigations most important work and
around 1920 he was shifted over to and
that division was shifted over to the
Bureau of Investigation our first call
for Richard ed powers comes from Fort
Smith Arkansas and her line for
Republicans good morning so I was one -
the author if he had read the cold 6,000
or American tabloid by James Ellroy and
wanted to see if he could get his
comment on the two novels I'm a big fan
of his writing and I was just want to
know what he thought I'll hang up listen
thank you five well
I'm afraid of a very short answer that
having read them okay let's go to
Landover Maryland on our line for
Democrats good morning yes sir how are
you today how it's both to you I didn't
I haven't had the pleasure reading your
book sir but I have read jag Hoover of
the man and the secrets by coach Gentry
and in his book he pretty much outlines
Hoover as public enemy number one more
or less the same line he gave about the
people he was trying to capture he had
his people try to arrest because he
never rested hardly anyone one of the
things that he mentioned is the Jo
Hoover and his boyfriend was the second
command Tolson had a secret slush fund
called the FBI recreational fund and he
had pretty much FBI agents writing books
for him ghost writers more or less on
public time and used the money from
these books too he put that in the so
called
FBI recreational fund where only he
Tolson and his earning command loot
knuckles had access to and they used the
money to go to Florida and all these
other places it's strangely enough in
looking at the pictures you have they're
the same pictures that are in this clip
Gentry book as well I will hang up to
listen to your comment well as far as
the pictures are concerned my book did
come out first on the other hand there's
a limited number of pictures there
largely in the National Archives and
Gentry went to the same source as I did
a Gentry's book is a pretty good book
he's a tremendous researcher and he dug
up some terrific sources he does take as
his guiding line you might say a
revisionist anti J Edgar Hoover
perspective which doesn't mean that any
of his facts are wrong but that there is
a particular slant to them as far as
this slush fund is concerned pretty much
everything that you've specified is
accurate on the other hand I would say
that there's no evidence that it was
totally misused in the sense that you're
saying most of the money did go into FBI
recreational activities and in the
context of the times the idea of
conflict of interest laws and the the
technicalities surrounding this sort of
activity we're not as tightly act as
they are today but I have to say guilty
as charged to everything you were saying
Richard good powers
this Collard raised an issue that I
thought we're going to get to eventually
during this hour and that is the
relationship between J Edgar Hoover and
his second-in-command Clyde Tolson at a
photograph here of the two of them at a
nightclub in New York tell us a little
bit about that there's a lot of
animations that the two of them had an
intimate relationship what's the story
there well this is an instance where I'm
afraid I have to depart from your orders
to stick with short answers because it's
it's somewhat involved but I'll try to
make it as brief as I can
Tolson was someone who came into the
Bureau about 1929 and had a meteoric
rise in about two or three years he was
an assistant director of the FBI and he
was j edgar Hoover's inseparable
companion
there were information suggestions
throughout Hoover's life that he was
homosexual and the most likely partner
certainly was Clyde Tolson as I said
they really were inseparable from the
early thirties until Hoover died now in
my book I did find some interesting
facts that led me in a certain direction
I found some photographs that Hoover had
taken of Tolson while Tolson was
sleeping and I think that most men would
recognize that this is somewhat of an
unforgivable invasion of privacy for one
man to do to another unless there was
something going on between them
secondly at one point Hoover was asked
to investigate an assistant deputy
secretary of state who had made a
homosexual pass in a Pullman Porter and
was going to lose his job because of it
and he was asked to find out what had
happened and Hoover made a very
interesting statement he said that well
this only happened when this fellow was
drunk and in that circumstance it shows
that all of us have to be on guard
against giving in to those kind of
inclinations well I don't think that
most heterosexual men would feel that
they were in any great danger of making
a pass at a Pullman Porter if they were
drunk so in both of those instances it
leads you to move in a certain direction
what I what I call the relationship was
a spousal relationship there really is
no evidence there was a sexual
relationship
but you know sex is a powerful force and
given the opportunity of cetera et
cetera I would tend to move in that
direction myself in that conclusion
although once again there is no hard and
fast evidence that someone once said the
people who know are talking and people
are talking don't know but let's move on
to the or I join me to continue on with
this question right now because this
moves then into the transvestite issue
well sure why don't we why don't we just
get to that right now
and talk about that okay that comes out
of another biography of Hoover by
Anthony summers a British journalist and
what he claimed in that book was that he
had a witness who had seen Jagger Hoover
in a dress at the moment I can't
remember whether was a a red dress a
white dress but anyway it was a puffy
party dress along with several other
notorious characters at one of New York
hotels and he actually got this woman
not only to give him a quote to that
effect but in a promo for his book to go
on camera and say that she had seen this
at the time I thought that this story
was extremely suspicious that there were
all sorts of logical reasons why it
couldn't be true I got in touch with the
woman and I wanted to talk to her and at
first she said she would then she said
she would if I paid her and then finally
it was for a very large sum of money and
then finally she wouldn't talk to me at
all and it seemed to me that someone
might have been influencing her not to
talk to me she was undergoing a very
messy divorce she was a wife of the
owner of Seagram distillers if I have
that right anyway what Schenley just
distillers and in the midst of this
divorce her estranged husband supposedly
came to her and said come with me to the
Waldorf Hotel and I'll show you
something interesting he brought her to
the hotel and then he Hoover Tolson
Roy Cohn put on a homosexual orgy for
her entertainment is that something that
a husband who is divorcing his wife and
is in midst of legal proceedings as
likely to be doing doesn't make much
sense to me furthermore the idea behind
the whole story is the following
the mob supposedly had gotten hold of
this information and therefore they were
able to blackmail Hoover into not
investigating the mob
let's carry the story a little bit
further because this is all in summers
book also he claims that the mob also
had sexual information about President
Kennedy and that kept Kennedy from
investigating the mob and finally that
Hoover had evidence of JFK's sexual
shenanigans
so that JFK couldn't order Hoover around
the only problem the whole story is that
we all know that once the Hoover's that
once the Kennedys took control of the
White House and Justice Department they
did unleash the FBI against the mob and
the FBI pursued them vigorously so the
story itself seems very suspicious to me
and the upshot the implication of it one
last factor there have been two books
specifically touching on this topic one
was by a fan Theo Harris and he wrote a
book sex lives in J Edgar Hoover I think
was a title in which he gave his
arguments why the story is not to be
believed that Hoover was a transvestite
then the most recent book a darn good
book by ron kessler called the bureau
history the FBI really nailed the story
he did manage to talk to rosensteil and
I think exposed her as a very unreliable
witness alright let's take a call for
Richard good powers from Cherry Hill New
Jersey on our line for Democrats good
morning yes hello I want to take you in
a slightly different direction and go
back to the comments that mr. Hoover was
not favorable to immigrants and some of
the repressive exit took place in the
FBI while he was leaving it I'm
wondering what um what lessons you would
draw from those from the research you
did particularly in the Cohens help Pro
period as we look at the implementation
of the u.s. Patriot Act today that's a
really good question because the there
are some parallels here
first and foremost Hoover's FBI really
went wildly astray starting about 1955
what had happened was that the bureau
had been able to surveil communists
justifying yet because the communists
were at least plausibly in violation of
the Smith Act which meant that if they
belong to an organization that advocated
you overthrow the government it could be
indicted so in other words the FBI had a
legal hook to hang its investigations on
in 1955 a Supreme Court said that it was
not going to countenance any more
prosecutions based on Smith Act
essentially saying that it was
unconstitutional though never quite came
to that so the FBI did something that
was at this perspective now absolutely
unjustified they decided that they would
secretly begin to use
counterintelligence techniques to
disrupt and harass the Communist Party
and they commenced to do so now within a
few years under the kennedy
administration they began to use the
same techniques against the Ku Klux Klan
in this case they did notify their
superiors then they went on to use the
same techniques against Black Panthers
and other black nationalist groups and
finally they were using them well
against the Socialist Workers Party but
they were also using them against the
student anti-war movement and the key
thing here is that they do were doing
things that were illegal and just plain
wrong against American citizens who
might have been unpopular but we're not
accused or guilty of any crimes and this
is you know an object lesson in what we
must never allow a law enforcement
organization to do now under the Patriot
Act you do have a mechanism for
unleashing the bureau to do intelligence
gathering operations which means
potentially at least they can gather
information about groups who as of the
moment have not committed any crimes and
maybe there's no evidence that they are
going to commit any crimes on the other
hand there's nothing in the Patriot Act
that would countenance disruptive
activities of the sort that you had in
COINTELPRO
they were really illegal then and
they're illegal now our next call
Kalispell Montana line for Republicans
good morning good morning I don't quite
understand what that guy's getting at I
was just the kid growing up when he when
the jailer Hoover started in there but
he made the FBI an organization that was
have there was the good feelings of
other law enforcement agencies and in
his book that he had he said he made the
statement that the Communists as a
communist as a communist and and that
was absolutely a hundred percent true
and still is but you can't tell it by
the way some of our politicians are they
still trying to deal with them you
cannot deal with the communists unless
he knows you've got the absolute power
to make him do so it's going to respond
scholar well the B phrase the communist
as a communist as a communist his it's
sort of true on the face the face of it
but even J Edgar Hoover realized that it
led him astray in one particular
instance after the assassination of John
F Kennedy he really went through you
know like a whirlwind his top officials
figuring out what had gone wrong he
considered this to be the worst disaster
in the history of the FBI and he was
told that the FBI had a series of
perhaps it had like checklist perhaps of
ten points that a an individual had to
fit into before he would be investigated
you have to see he had to subscribe to
The Daily Worker he had to go to
Communist Party meetings etc etc this
meant that the FBI was surveilling some
over-the-hill party hacks who weren't
doing much except sitting around in
parks and playing chess and on the other
hand they were not keeping their eye on
Lee Harvey Oswald who was a
self-proclaimed communist and who was
obviously dangerous and when one of his
top officials tried to excuse themselves
by saying that Lee Harvey Oswald didn't
fit all the criteria Hoover himself said
that anyone in the world could have seen
this was exactly the sort of person they
should have been watching so a communist
is a communist is a communist
it may be true in some senses but law
enforcement has to be a little more
discriminating in a lot richer gate
powers let me take you back to the early
2000 late 20s early 30s which i think is
is judging from your book when J Edgar
Hoover became begin to become a famous
public figure give us a sense of what it
was like back then your book suggests
that the crime situation was out of
control and quite different from the way
it is today the the situation as far as
crime was concerned in the early
depression is very interesting it's
almost a a case study in political
psychology what happened was you had a
fair amount of crime during the 1920s
but after the crash crime began to be
interpreted by the public as a test of
whether the government was able to do
its job and under President Herbert
Hoover no relation to J Edgar Hoover it
seemed that the government was not able
to do its job because in some of the
high-profile crimes and some of the
high-profile criminals of time Al Capone
the Lindbergh kidnapping the government
was not able to react quickly enough and
it was not able to react in a way that
the public really set interpreted as the
right response so when the Roosevelt
administration came in with a new
Attorney General and they began to
interpret crimes high-profile crimes as
challenges in the country declarations
of war by criminals against the country
it was something that the public really
exalted in and when Hoover managed to
capture or kill people like Machine Gun
Kelly babyface Nelson Pretty Boy Floyd
and of course John Dillinger it really
was interpreted by the country as a
tremendous boost to its self-confidence
this really meant that the country even
though it was in very hard times was
going to survive with its value system
intact the criminals were not going to
rule the country and then Hollywood took
over Hollywood made a series of g-men
pictures beginning in 1935
it turned the FBI and it turns edgar
Hoover into popular celebrities and that
was really what made Jade GRU Hoover too
big for anyone to touch now he added
dimension to them afterwards but once he
became a Hollywood hero he was something
that was really operating on a whole
different level than a normal politician
certainly in a normal bureaucrat now he
had a talent for being at the scene of
the arrest of some of these guys did he
not in the mid thirties one of his
congressional opponents a senator
Mackellar ridiculed him during an
Appropriations Committee meeting hearing
that he had never actually arrested
anyone himself and so for the next two
years or so you couldn't keep jagger
who've in the office he showed up to
arrest the then public enemy number one
Alvin creepy Karpis on Canal Street in
New Orleans he arrested Harry brunetti
here in New York City and it was clearly
quite a spectacle at that point J goo
Hoover was in his 40s and you know he
was really a bureaucrat high-level
administrator yet he was running around
the country slapping the cuffs on on
people so it was really quite a
spectacle but it was something that was
precipitated by a confrontation that he
had with one senator our next call for
Richard good powers from Hamilton
Montana on our line for Democrats good
morning good morning good morning
Attorney yep
hear you fine okay I wanted to mention
something about J Edgar Hoover I'm from
La Jolla California I'm a lady bird
lawyer and he used to come to my Hawaii
to go to Scripps Clinic for his annual
checkup I worked at a very elite resort
there at the time of the McCarthy
hearings and he stayed at this resort in
a little bungalow with Clyde Tolson he
was a very pleasant man now one day I'll
get to the point fast we had all our
cars out so McCarthy's brother was to
arrive at the airport that's Joe
McCarthy's brother and they had no one
to go and pick him up for it asked if I
would go pick him up
I said sure I picked him up and I did so
took him to La Jolla and Jill McCarthy's
brother with his little briefcase headed
right to that bungalow no stops so I've
always figured in the years in between
that there was a connection here between
him and Hoover and you know the
communist uprising that they had over
the actors and writers in Hollywood and
I'm sure there's a connection there but
I can never figure it out but anyway I
wanted to say also that the man was
always very pleasant to me Clyde Tolson
was always very pleasant and as far as
immigrants are concerned my father was
an immigrant and they sure treated him
well he was in the restaurant business
and they frequented his restaurant and
liked him and he liked them so there you
go you know there's two sides to every
person okay call her thanks mr. powers
any response to that the connection
between Joe McCarthy and well there
certainly was a connection between
Hoover and McCarthy McCarthy was a
completely irresponsible anti-communist
who was liable to say the first thing
that came into his head and then he
would run to Hoover asking for some
facts to back it up and Hoover was in a
position where he couldn't quite
repudiate McCarthy because McCarthy was
enormous ly popular among Hoover's own
backers that would be the right wing of
the country on the other hand he knew
that McCarthy was really bad news for
the anti-communist movement because he
would be caught up eventually in his own
lies that's what happened and Hoover at
a very key point in the decline and fall
of Joe McCarthy did publicly repudiate
him as far as the other point is
concerned about Hoover's attitude
towards immigrants I really was too
sweeping in that statement before where
I said he was suspicious of immigrants
he was suspicious of radicalism and he
thought that radicalism was a foreign
import and so it's more proper to say
that he was suspicious of radicalism
among immigrants Houston Texas good
morning you're on c-span I
there was a book written about five
years ago about Hoover happening black
access sir and matter of fact the lady
she looked at his birth certificate and
found that it was tampered with
maybe that was for the reason why Hoover
had a hard time with blacks because of
his secret pass the book was written
about five years ago do you have any
comments about that book have you ever
read it yeah I have read it I have
looked into the book and I'm very
skeptical about nearly everything that's
in the book and one of the things that
you can look for yourself is if you get
my book you can look at pictures of
Hoover's mother and then look at
pictures of / and we know what Hoover's
mother was and we know her ancestry
which was a Swiss ancestry and you know
they are amazingly similar actually
there's a picture there flashing right
up there now and that does look like
over in a black dress doesn't it I I
don't think that there's anything to it
on the other hand Hoover did have in
some sense some features that were you
want stereotypically Negro features he
had broad lips
his hair was very tightly curly and so
you know I can see how someone would
move in that direction but I'm very
skeptical of the woman's conclusions and
of the facts that she brings to bear our
next call comes from Santa Barbara
California good morning good morning yes
I've been waiting for your call anyway I
would do what to disagree with a few
things but I had a very good privilege
of stick you with a princess many years
ago I had a talk show in Bakersfield
California and one of my guest was a
princess who had escaped from communism
in Romania her name was Princess
Catherine Carozza I just had with her
information if you want it but that's
what I was first called asked if I would
like to have her on my show I was
Turrell to that of course and announced
on the error that she would be seeking
on communism when I picked her up at the
station
she became furious I am NOT going to be
talking about coming
well needless to say I was shocked what
are you going to be talking about your
topic I'm going to be talking how you
Americans are losing your freedom
through your apathy and your complacency
and look what's happened I frankly wish
we had Jagger who were backs he may have
been homosexual I don't care for that
that's not the point but we did not have
the traitors that we have at this as far
as I know we do not have the traitors in
that we have today we did not have half
Henson and who are the other things
because uh he ran a Bureau that was free
of them but Deb I heard Angela Davis Lee
are you up I heard Angela Davis the
first time she spoke at UCLA who
advocated the overthrow of the United
States government to our tech supported
campus I happen to be a public speaker
in heaven for many years I got a foot
argued with her oh and she found out
that I but not in her camp she did they
tried to take the microphone away from
me and I wouldn't let them anyway I
finally said to her could you possibly
speak of capitalism in Russia that is
completely a revelant I said the heck it
is okay let's get a response here is it
true that there have been some highly
publicized revelations of spies inside
the CIA the FBI lately was that true
during the Hoover era or not no it was
not and I think that an awful lot of
laxity had crept into the bureau in the
post Hoover era Hoover's control of his
agents was really all-encompassing his
goal really wasn't an agent could
literally do nothing at all
minute by minute without reporting on
what he was doing to his superiors and
eventually to Hoover and so I think it
was almost beyond comprehension or
beyond credibility that an agent could
become a spy could become a mole in over
era FBI and in reaction to that I
probably had been in to a certain extent
still is
too much relaxation of these internal
controls over FBI agents so the FBI
really has been hit by some incredibly
disgraceful incidents where their own
agents have turned out to be traitors
against a country and to give whoever
his due I doubt that would have been
possible in his era Richard did powers
we have a photo here of the Bureau of
Investigation in the early days and tell
us a little bit something I keep trying
to get back to and we keep getting taken
in other directions but before we lose
the opportunity what why how did J Edgar
Hoover come to be director and what did
he do to change the nature of that
Bureau when he did become director the
the time when Hoover was moved up to
director of the FBI first assistant
Acting Director the FBI was in 1923 when
the country was caught up in a series of
government scandals called the Teapot
Dome scandal and the Department of
Justice was discredited and the bureau
of investigation was particularly
discredited so Hoover was appointed
assistant director and then in 1924
assistant director and then in 1924 he
was appointed director of the bureau by
Harlan stone and what he was told to do
was to remove the bureau from any
investigations that did not pertain to
federal crimes and to strictly limit his
investigations to cut down on a number
of agents and so forth so it was a
disgraced Bureau and his job for the
first say eight or nine years that he
was director was to keep the FBI FBI out
of the news and what he did he was a
very energetic person he wasn't content
to do less and less every year is he
made the FBI the leader of the police
professionalism movement in the country
which put the FBI in the vanguard of a
movement started by other people
actually started by a Berkeley
California police chief and by a few
other progressive police chase
throughout the country but the FBI
became the symbol of police
professionalism which meant independence
from politics and the use of scientific
law enforce
and so by the time the Roosevelt
administration for political reasons
began to publicize the bureau the bureau
was already very well known in law
enforcement community and highly
respected our next call for Richard GUID
powers comes from Kearney Nebraska on
our line for Democrats good morning
yes I'd uh like no did not the FBI know
that Patty Hearst was going to be
abducted I don't know no the FBI didn't
know she's going to be abducted
all right let's go to Madison Wisconsin
on our line for independence good
morning good morning thanks for taking
my call in reading the book the birth of
Stalin there's a a couple of statements
on 183 and it relates to this was
uncovered when they released some of the
docked secret documentation in the
archives over and I believe Moscow and
it was a memo from Boris Reinstein who
was a communist sympathizer in this
country and he wrote a note to Lenin and
he let him made some notes and pass it
on to Stalin and they had to do with
comrade Julius hammer and his son Armand
and the fact that the doctor Julius
hammer was one of the main financial
raisers of money for the communist party
back in those days and Lenin the letter
he passed on indicated how important it
was to keep this secret so that it would
not be uncovered now in other books that
I've read I've understood that J Edgar
Hoover was on to the hammer family and
their support for communism but that
three senators namely Al Gore senior and
I believe the senator from New Hampshire
and one other from the Northeast put us
more or less a stop to putting them in
jail and of course the son Armand Hammer
became a primary supporter of Al Gore as
various runs for president back in 88
and since then also headed up Occidental
Petroleum who my understanding is that
Al Gore jr. pushed through this largest
sale in the history
of the nation of public land to a
private concern and naturally it was
Occidental okay let's get a response
here well I'm familiar with the broad
issues involved in the Armand Hammer
career and Hammer and his family you
know were deeply involved in careering
money from the Soviet Union to the
American Communist Party and furthermore
in I guess repayment for that service
hammer was given all sorts of
concessions in the Soviet Union as far
as doing business was concerned so
there's no doubt that the hammer was
deeply involved in activities that were
opposed to the interests of the United
States but as far as the specifics in
relationships between hammer and the
gore family I'm not familiar with those
but I would say that hammer had managed
to acquire so much influence that I
would not be surprised if you weren't
able to find a much broader spectrum of
congressmen and Senators who also came
to the aid of hammer when he asked for
that aid and none of them presumably
were aware of his activities
Richard good powers we have an email
from a viewer who asks lust for big
money seems to be the reason for all our
troubles observing what's going on today
what was Hoover's salary in his day and
did he die wealthy a Hoover did die
rather wealthy and the the source of the
wealth were tips given to him on oil
investments by his wealthy Texas oil
interest friends the murchison x' hunts
among others so he was more than lucky
as far as his investments were concerned
he was brought in to good things
repeatedly as far as his salary was
concerned you know he was paid a
government service administration salary
according to his rank and while it was
you know a nice sum of money it wasn't
anything extraordinary and it certainly
was nothing comparable to what he could
have made in private industry and by the
a you have the same problem today if
indeed it's a problem and that is that
to administer an organization like the
FBI takes a fantastic amount of
administrative talent and yet the head
of the FBI makes only in a neighborhood
of $150,000 and in the case of last
director Louis Freeh that turned into an
enormous financial sacrifice since he
had a good number of children who were
approaching college age Richard kid
powers is the author of this book the
life of secrecy and power a life of j
edgar Hoover he got his PhD at Brown
University in what mr. powers American
civilization and now directs the
graduate program in American Studies at
the City University of New York teaches
history at the College of Staten Island
been studying the FBI since 1975 lives
alternately in Brooklyn and New Orleans
why those two places my wife is the
headmistress of a very fine girl school
in New Orleans Louisiana G school and
natural I want to spend as much time as
I can with her you know as somebody
who's lived in New Orleans if you'll
permit me to observe that there the
accent in both Brooklyn and New Orleans
is very similar you find that to be the
case amazingly so our next call for
Richard did Powers comes from
saturdaya Virginia good morning good
morning talking about the transvestite
stories about mr. Hoover it's the funny
thing but I read in the newspaper a a
while back that this was one of the lies
of KGB disinformation that was put out
by the Russians and it was revealed when
the KGB files were opened and that was
one of the things that came out I read
it in the newspaper I'm surprised that
you don't know about that well I don't
know about a lot of things that's not
too surprising in that particular
instance I haven't heard that story all
right let's go to Germantown Tennessee
good morning good morning and thank you
this is very interesting I'm fascinated
with Hoover I would like to say
something real quick and then ask three
short questions
someone said something about Hoover
being good there's a wonderful quote
from John Dos Passos if there's one
thing that mankind should have learned
from all of its Agony's it is never safe
to do evil that good may come of it the
good gets lost and the evil goes on and
that's one of my problems with mr.
Hoover he seemed to have so many
dichotomies about what he was and the
first question I'd like to ask as you
mentioned the one thing that you thought
Hoover did wrong was he stayed too long
did anyone ever approach or attempt or
try to get Hoover to move on out in his
twilight years yes
eternity general her--as Brownell around
1959 went to Hoover and told him that it
is time for you to move on and that if
you continue in office you're going to
taint a fantastic reputation that you've
built up over the years
Hoover ignored that advice and perhaps
the reason he ignored the advice is he
was a single man his whole life was
wrapped up in the bureau he didn't like
the changes that were occurring the
United States and so he kept the bureau
a kind of well almost theme park if you
want to use kind of an inappropriate
term a theme park in which was
encapsulated the kind of America he grew
up in and so there was really no place
for Hoover outside the FBI and you
didn't particularly like what was
outside the FBI so he did stay on he
stayed on and he turned himself into not
worse than just a curmudgeon somebody
who was opposing often secretly what
large segments of the public thought was
necessary which was a change in the
racial relationships in the country a
greater tolerance of diversity and
dissent in the country and so he turned
himself in the FBI into forces that
we're really trying to force some of the
major tendencies in America at the time
all right I think that do we still have
that last caller on the line yeah yes
you gotta come more questions caller guy
I missed I missed the first part of your
question just remind me I'll get back to
it I've well
I'd like to move on to something else
recently there were suggestions made
that the FBI building which has J edgar
Hoover's name on it should be renamed in
light of all that has come to surface in
the many books I'd like to know what
your feeling is on that I think a great
title for it would just be put the
following quote up there absolute power
corrupts and it corrupts absolutely
color did you have one more thing you
wanted to ask before we let you go yes
I'm on my own yeah yeah I'll just be a
quick blast I'd like to know what he
thinks about the suggestion for renaming
the FBI building from the J Gruber
building to another something else
okay thanks yeah I'd be completely
opposed to that and I say that
recognizing you know the motives behind
what you've said and about behind the
suggestion by the way it's a suggestion
that a columnist for Washington Post
makes repeatedly and a number of people
in Congress have made but you really
can't wipe out a whole era of the
nation's past just because of the
changing attitudes toward it I think
actually it's better to keep the name on
there as a reminder to the FBI
both of some of the glorious parts of
its past but also reminding it of how
much it had gone astray in the past I
don't really think you should blank out
things like that was there any
controversy about naming the building
for J Edgar Hoover when it was named for
him no at that point you have to bear in
mind he died 1972 and while he was
really cordially hated by the left in
this country and to a certain extent
within the liberal community as well the
evidence for his misdeeds and not come
out until 1975 and so you had a period
in between where while he certainly was
a controversial figure and certainly
were people who had no use for him you
didn't have hard and fast evidence of
what he had done that was illegal until
1975 when there was a senatorial
investigation headed by Frank Church of
Idaho Phoenix Arizona good morning
you're on c-span with Richard did powers
yeah good morning thank you I disagree
about that not read
I see just named a building the FBI
building because I just finished reading
a book I don't know if you've read it
it's called the pker life J Edgar Hoover
by Anthony summers I have run it yes
yeah and I find some disturbing evidence
in there and I don't know if it's
factored in fiction or what you know
what it is but one of the things I saw
is is he didn't really like the Kennedys
too much and I'm wondering did he know
that the assassination was going to take
place did he know Lee Harvey Oswald
thank you very much yes well that's a
really important question first of all
he did not like the Kennedys I didn't
like him for a number of reasons and one
is that they were pushing him in
directions that he didn't want to go as
far as integrating the FBI was concerned
he was also being pushed by them to
engage in civil rights investigations
that he didn't feel would be fruitful as
far as convictions were concerned and
also ran against his own prejudices
against Blacks and his view of the
proper place of blacks in American
society which was in a subordinate
position as far as Lee Harvey Oswald was
concerned no the FBI did not know that
Oswald is going to assassinate the
Kennedy John F Kennedy but they probably
should have been a lot more suspicious
no not probably they certainly should
have more been more suspicious of him
and they should have kept him under
tighter surveillance after all and I'm
sure you're aware of this has Wald went
into the Dallas FBI field office and
threatened the agents there with
violence if they didn't stop harassing
him and his wife now it seems to me and
it seemed to almost anyone that that in
itself is reason to keep him under very
tight surveillance particularly since he
had this extremely unusual background of
having defected to the Soviet Union of
having come back of having gotten
involved in very extreme aunt pro-castro
activities of having applied for
membership in the American Communist
Party there were all sorts of reasons
why the FBI should have been on to this
character and yet they did not keep them
under survey
mr. powers in your book there's a copy
of a memorandum and J edgar Hoover's
handwriting is here in which he calls
Martin Luther King a tomcat with ABS
with looks like degenerate sexual urges
he tell us what that was all about
Martin Luther King jr. was the target of
probably the worst of all of the FBI
harassment finally one of Hoover's top
lieutenants a man named William C
Sullivan sent Martin Luther King jr. a
letter actually addressed so that it
would arrive at his house where his wife
would open it in which had accused who
king of sexual crimes sexual offenses
and then said to King there's only one
way out and it seemed unmistakable to
what the letter was doing was suggesting
suicide to King so that's how bad it got
now the the background for this which
has really been developed by a terrific
historian named David Garrow is that the
FBI had an informant within the
communist party who notified the bureau
that one of Martin Luther King Jr's top
advisors had been a very important
member of the Communist Party had
dropped out and so therefore might be a
mole and so at that point
Hoover launched which an investigation
which in the context of the day was a
legitimate investigation to find out the
extent of communist influence on Martin
Luther King jr. in the course of that
investigation
Hoover uncovered King's secret sex life
and that was something that Hoover then
began to use against King once King
emerged as a critic of the FBI because
probably worse than being a communist
and worse than been a public official
who was leading a secret sex life was to
be a critic of the FBI that meant that
you were an enemy of everything that was
good and everything that was American
and so from that point on Hoover pitted
himself as a sworn enemy of Martin
Luther King jr. and began to try to use
evidence sexual evidence against king
jupiter florida good morning you're on
c-span good morning how are you I would
I'd like to address you know his
sexuality of sexuality I've known this
man for many years I'm from Baltimore
and he used to go to all the racetracks
and I remember one day out there
when Seabiscuit was running against
whirlaway in that very very famous race
back in the 40s and he was surrounded by
all women and I must have seen him a
hundred times at Bowie and Laurel and
Pimlico
and I disagree with some of these people
they'd call it thank you very much well
I would just refer back to my statements
before which is that there are
suggestive bits of evidence that point
you in the direction of suspecting that
he was you can also use word homo social
which means preferring the company of
men there is no evidence at all that
Hoover was heterosexual he certainly did
have women among his friends but then as
I said before the people that really
know aren't talking and the people who
are talking really don't know when it
comes to his homosexuality Las Vegas
Nevada good morning good morning I like
to just I had a different experience
with mr. Jagger Hoover I I lived in
Vallejo during just after or around the
bombing of Pearl Harbor and a family
friend of mine were of Japanese they
were Americans but they were of Japanese
descent so they were shipped off to
internment and their property was taken
by Americans at ten cents on the dollar
was you know I I always thought this is
the worst thing we ever did to anybody
and so in night I got during the war I
got hooked up with the remnants of the
442nd and hand 111th battalion of nisi
and ever since then I've been I was on a
little bit of a thing I ended up doing a
pro bono I tried to
lobby Congress to give these people the
right to become citizens these people
because of the Asian exclusion during
those years and in the 50s they couldn't
even become citizens yet they fought
unlike one of our presidents mr. Reagan
and like the Duke Wayne who didn't go to
war these guys win but they couldn't
become citizens so I went back and and I
lobbied for nothing
it gets his bill through and I had to go
see mr. Hoover because everybody told me
I better do it so he graciously gave me
one hour didn't know me from Adam and we
talked over the whole problem and I even
though he may have some little problems
he sure gave me a lot of help and he
told me a you know a couple little
stories to use on some of the Senators
and some of the House of Representatives
so he gave me a big boost on getting
this thing through and so one of I think
I really felt good about getting this
roof with the people who couldn't become
American citizen that spotlight hill for
us mr. Hart yeah that's a terrific story
and one of the areas where Hoover
unmistakeably came down on the right
side of a very controversial issue was
on the internment of Japanese American
citizens Hoover advocated that that not
be done he recommended and not be done
and his reasons were very clear
he and his Bureau had been on top of the
Nazi and the Japanese on the ground in
this country and within hours after
Pearl Harbor they had rounded up
everyone that they considered to be
involved in espionage and potential
sabotage activities in the United States
and so he told his superiors that there
was no reason to round up the Nisei to
round up these people and for evermore
that all it was happening was response
to unjustified a stereo on the west
coast and furthermore Hoover was then
asked later on in the
a war to make an investigation of the
law-enforcement situation within the
internment camps and once again in the
course of making that investigation he
pointed out that the whole thing was
unjustifiable mr. powers we have we're
almost out of time but I wanted just to
get you quickly to I wanted to go
through all the presidents and I think
there were seven that j edgar hoover
served during their administrations but
what about the best in the worst
relationship with the president the best
relationship best work relationship with
her was with Franklin D Roosevelt
Roosevelt gave Hoover some very
difficult jobs to do during the mid
thirties when the isolationist and
anti-war sentiment was so strong in this
country Roosevelt knew what war was on
its way he of course was trying to rearm
the country but is also trying to stay
on top of the Nazi movement in this
country and for that matter the
communist movement in this country
and so in a very delicate way Hoover got
the bureau back into the business of
domestic surveillance of these foreign
affiliated groups needed a great job
during World War two he also performed a
great service for Franklin Roosevelt in
staying on top of Nazi saboteurs and so
forth so that was really the most
productive relationship in in Hoover's
career the worst relationships well
there were two of them really one was
under Harry Truman when Hoover all but
pitted the FBI against the Truman
administration on the communists and
government issue
he was very disloyal to Harry Truman and
then there was John F Kennedy and once
again this was a president that Tovar
despised and president whose values he
really rejected on the other hand in a
couple instances he proved himself to be
a loyal soldier to John F Kennedy let's
see if we can't squeeze in at least one
more phone call here for Richard did
power Scottsburg Indiana good morning
yes sir
mr. Pires I had a brother who was in
World War two he was on Iwo Jima and
Guam he later went to night school
became a lawyer
went with the FBI worked with them for
number of years and finally when he died
he was working with the House
Appropriations Committee and recently my
nephew sent me a lot of information
concerning my brother and there's a lot
of correspondence in there
some of it pretty detailed and I just
wondered if you were aware that they
gave a cent of award to some of the I
guess the agents for work well done it
seems like a fitness today but he got to
hunt $64 that was a $200 reward less
taxes and I was wondering if he was
aware that they that they did that you
know I was looking at some of the
correspondence and it showed that he
really did a great job on several cases
and he got these awards where you know
foreign intelligence and a lot of other
things were involved it seems like not
too much by today's standards you know
as this one if he was aware of that yeah
I was in the the method that Hoover used
to stay on top of his agents involved
constant reporting but also constant
awarding of either demerits or merits
and the demerits would cost the agents
money and the merits would give them
some money so it was a carrot and stick
approach that was applicable all through
Hoover's ha era Richard did powers as
the author of this book